(upbeat music)
- Yeah, I like big butts.
- I like big butts on men and women.
- I want a big butt, but because I'm a guy
I don't feel like I'm
allowed to want a big butt.
Everybody wants a nice ass.
- Well, I think anyone with a bigger butt
gets a lot of attention.
- His Butt Booster.
- Right away it kinda feels like a bra.
- So, there's like the title tag
and then on the back of it
there's no other information.
- Here's my flat butt.
(twinkling music)
Oh my god, I'm so happy in these.
- So I just put the underwear on.
My pants feel very filled out.
And these pants are like
usually totally filled out
by just my natural ass, but like damn.
- I sat down in a chair
right after I put this on
and I can tell why people with
big butts have such big egos.
'Cause they're so high
up, and I'm into it.
It'll be interesting
to see if anybody else
can tell the difference.
- Your pants look tight.
Oh god, why is it so hard?
- It kinda feels like a real butt.
- Oh, that's a firm butt.
- Thank you so much.
- (Tall Man) Good job.
- I did people do squats for a month.
- Do you like it?
- No, it's kinda weird.
- (laughing) oh.
- One benefit of the big
butt that I will miss
is that when I sit on people's laps,
they don't talk about
how bony my cheeks are.
- I think before I
thought I was more happy
with the shape of my
butt than I actually am.
And I think going through
this just made me realize
I actually don't want the explosive
like Nicki Minaj butt that I think I want.
- I think I had the most fun
I've had in a really long time.
The grass is greener, let me tell you.
It's fuller, too.
- [Voiceover] What do you think?
- I think I like the
real thing better, but...
- Uh, uh, uh
- Where is HR?